i mean if we want to turn the death of  the earth into capital we're doing a  good job what do you do with that  capital part of that priority is  short-term gains over long-term  well-being for all well the capitalist  system really takes life and turns it  into money but i do think you're seeing  in corporations a real big shift the  idea being that we can create  a non-extractive relationship with the  planet without having to you know throw  capitalism to the wind the extraction  would be the economic benefit that  someone would get out of changing the  relationship with the planet to be  symbiotic and regenerative i mean what  meaning does money have if it's an  unlivable planet